Yo whats going on guys? Rock here, I am super pumped you guys are going to check out my new movie Jumanji. I play a world explorer, I may have a super strength or two and plus I'm a guy who can take down anything with a boomerang. Jungle Style.
Enjoy.
Well, this is a fun group. Welcome to detention. Spencer. Bethany. Fridge. Martha. You're all here for a reason.
Hey!!! Person walking. You should be thinking about who  you are. And who you want to be.
You'll have plenty of time to figure that out while you're cleaning out the basement.
Are you gonna help or are you too pretty? I'm too pretty.
Yo. What's this?
A game for those who seek to find
A way to leave their world behind.
Jumanji.
Pick a character and you're that person in the game. Which one do I pick?
I don't think it matters that much. Moose Finbar sounds like a badass. I'll be the curvy genius.
Dr Smolder Bravestone.
Guess I'm Ruby Roundhouse.
Guys!
Where's the rest of me?
Oh My God. Fridge?
Yeah I'm Fridge, who are you? It's me Spencer.
Who is she?
Martha?
Why am I wearing half a shirt and short- shorts in the Jungle?!
I think we got sucked into Jumanji and we've become the avatars we chose.
So that means... Bethany?
Bethany! Don't look at it.
No!!
I'm an overweight middle aged man.
I don't have my Claritin and all I see around here is pollen.
Well I don't have the top two feet of my body.
Damn that is a man right there.
Don't cry, don't cry.
Don't cry, it's gonna be okay.
This is a video game which means we all have special skills.
Why am I running so slow?!
That was so intense. I like can't even with this place.
Watch your step in here.
Maybe we're all in a coma. What?
That old game machine must have electrocuted us and now we're...
OH MY GOD!! Ahhh!
You'd better get in there and save her.
I'm not gonna get in there. You get in there.
I got a backpack on! You don't get in the water with a backpack, everyone knows that.